uh thanks uh Patrick
and good afternoon everyone nearly one
year ago
I first convened what became the Ukraine
defense contact group right here
at Ramstein
our goal was to improve the coordination
of our support for Ukraine
as it fought back against Russia's
Reckless
and Lawless invasion
over the past year this contact group
has become
an extraordinary community of action
and together we have rallied to defend
the principles of democracy
freedom
and sovereignty
so we're all back here at Ramstein a
year later
to build on that impressive progress
over the past year the members of this
contact group have provided tremendous
capability to Ukraine
right after Russia invaded
we surged in javelins and stingers
and then we provided Ukraine's Defenders
with howitzers
hi Mars
in other artillery
and we continue to rush in ground-based
air defense capabilities and Munitions
to help Ukraine control its Sovereign
Skies
and to help Ukraine defend its citizens
from
Russian cruise missiles in Iranian
drones
our Collective efforts have made a huge
difference on the battlefield
and now in just a few short months the
contact group has delivered
more than 230 types
more than 1 550 armored vehicles and
other equipment and munitions
to support more than nine new armored
brigades
we've also expedited our M1 Abrams
timelines to
Supply Ukraine with more armored
capability in the coming months
and the M1 said the ukrainians will use
for training
will arrive here in Germany in the next
few weeks
all of this
is huge progress
and I am confident that this equipment
in the training that accompanied it it
will put Ukraine's forces in a position
to continue to succeed on the
battlefield
Ukraine's forces have
formidable capability and courage
we've seen throughout
and all this progress rests on the
coordinated work of some 50 nations of
Goodwill
that have gathered
again today
no let me say just a few words about the
reports of
unauthorized disclosure of sensitive and
classified U.S material
I take this matter extremely seriously
and we will continue to work closely and
with our deeply valued allies and
partners
in a spirit of abiding respect and
friendship
as I've discussed this issue with our
allies and partners
I've been struck by their solidarity
and their commitment
to reject efforts to the virus
so nothing will fracture our Unity or
reduce our determination
now I'm grateful to my good friend Alexi
reznikov
for joining us at Ramstein
and he once again
gave us all a first-hand account of the
battlefield Dynamics
highlighting Ukraine's most urgent needs
in the critical months ahead
we also heard from my colleagues in U.S
European command
about the progress on building Ukraine's
combat power as Ukraine prepares to push
back
the lines of Russian invade Invaders
and we talked about key enablers that
will help Ukraine repel Russian forces
such as heavy equipment
transport vehicles and refuelers and
mine rollers
and I'd like to thank those here who
announced donations
of these important systems including
Germany and the Netherlands
we also discuss ways to intensify our
sustainment
in industrial-based initiatives
now Russia has continued its assault on
civilian Targets in Ukraine including
schools and theaters and apartment
buildings
those targets have absolutely no
military value whatsoever
so we're hoping Ukraine defended
citizens in Disguise against Russian
missiles and Iranian drones
now many contact group members have
stepped up with new air defense systems
and critically needed ammunition for
those systems
and we're going to stay focused on the
key capabilities that Ukraine needs
right now
as well as intermediate terms
now we also heard today from the
European Union
on this proposal to speed up the
production and delivery of ammunition
for Ukraine
and more countries are thinking about
how they can increase
industrial production not just for the
near term but also for the median term
and the long term
and that is a powerful reminder
that we stand with Ukraine's Defenders
for the Long Haul
you know Putin made a series of grave
miscalculations
when he ordered the invasion of Ukraine
more than a year ago
he thought that Ukraine wouldn't dare to
fight back
but Ukraine is standing strong with the
help of his partners
Putin thought that our Unity was
fracture
but Russia's cruel war of choice
has only brought us closer together
and I'd note that Finland
which has long taken part in this
contact group
is here today is a new NATO Ally
I expect the Sweden will soon follow
and that makes something crystal clear
Putin's war of choice is not the result
of NATO enlargement
Putin's war is the cost of NATO's
enlargement
you know when I first convened this
contact group
I saw a nations of Goodwill that were
eager to help Ukraine
resist Russia's Imperial aggression
I saw a coalition that stood United and
firmly
I saw countries determined to stand up
for an open and secure world
of Rights and rules
in all of that was just as true
and Ramstein today
as it was a year ago
the UK ukrainians are still standing
strong
in their fight for their freedom
they have the courage and the capability
for the road ahead
and we will have their backs
for as long as it takes
so with that I'll turn it over to the
church
thanks secretary and I want to start off
by thanking secretary Austin for his
leadership over the past year in this
11th Ukrainian defense contact Group
which has resulted in enormous support
to Ukraine not only from the countries
of Europe but really from the globe and
it wouldn't be happening without
secretary Austin's leadership so thank
you sir and thanks also to the ministers
and Chiefs of Defense from over 50
countries that attended today in a
consistently attended now for a year and
their participation and support is
critical to the capability of the
Ukrainian military to defend itself
it's been nearly a year since secretary
Austin began his contact group right
here at ramstop and this forum has been
vital to coordinate and synchronize the
support continued International support
to Ukraine I also want to thank
Ukrainian minister of defense resnikov
and and my colleague and partner chief
of Defense General Solutions whom I've
had a chance to contact in the last week
or so and his representative here Joe
moistu for their continued leadership
and also congratulate Finland on their
recession into NATO
this historic event marks a deepening of
the NATO alliance and reaffirms to the
world the strength of this relationship
but this is not just about the United
States and European security nato in
this contact group helped to uphold
something bigger than that they uphold
the global international order
for all nations and live in peace to
prosper a world that respects
sovereignty and the rule of law
a world that counters unbridled military
aggression
421 days ago
Putin thought he could overthrow the
Ukrainian government
decided to fracture NATO as he launched
an unprovoked war of aggression hundreds
of thousands of Russian forces crossing
the border on multiple Avenues of
approach he was wrong
Ukraine Spirit remains Unbroken
there are now 31 members of NATO
and NATO is even stronger and United in
the face of Russia's oppression and its
attack in the rules-based order
the United States and the members of
this contact group remain committed
to supporting Ukraine as a fight for
Freedom against Russia's illegal and
unprovoked invasion
to date the United States has committed
more than 35 million dollars military
assistance including over 2 million
tanks and artillery routers tens of
thousands of anti-armor weapon systems
air defense systems and other forms of
Munitions hundreds of tanks and armored
vehicles
Precision aerial Munitions encounter uas
capabilities
in addition
there's about 2500 Ukrainian soldiers
conducting training right now in German
another 8 800 almost 9 000 have
completed training and have returned to
Ukraine
and there are 65 ukrainians that
completed training on Patriot missile
systems just recently
since the early phases of this war
and for every month since the United
States has provided Ukraine
the capabilities to defend itself
and in conjunction with our allies and
partners we have delivered
this Coalition will continue to provide
vital training and additional
capabilities for air defense and
maneuver to enable Ukraine's ongoing
fight
air defense munitions
air defense capabilities tank conditions
armored vehicle capabilities artillery
ammunition artillery tubes and Rockets
and spare parts remain critical as
Ukraine protects its cities and expels
the Russian Menace for its territory
our countries and the countries of
Europe have pledged and Ukraine will
have the capabilities it needs to
execute their missions on their own
timeline we have pledged that support
for as long as it takes as the secretary
just said
this week the United States announced
our latest security assistance package
as part of our ongoing commitment to
Ukraine
as we stand here today the Ukrainian
military continues to perform very well
intense fighting and around black move
continues and has for several months
Russia is expending significant Manpower
for very little gain
Russia is intensifying indiscriminate
shelling a beaker in other cities and
urban areas
and Russia continues to pay severely for
its war of choice
unlike Ukrainian forces who are highly
motivated to fight for their country
to fight for their freedom their
democracy and their way of life
the Russians lack of leadership they
lack will the morale is poor and the
discipline is eroded
Russia has resorted to tightening
conscription laws as they
indiscriminately feed their citizens
into the chaos of War
and so far they've been quite
ineffective in the coordination or
direction of combining arms maneuver on
the battlefield
over the past year Russia's temporary
territorial gains have come with
enormous losses
hundreds of thousands of Russians have
fled their country in addition to the
casualties they are trying to avoid
fighting it in Putin's War
Russia continues to fail in achieving
its strategic objectives
they failed to seize Kiev they failed
the top of the Ukrainian government and
they failed to fracture NATO
in fact they've done just the opposite
key stands
the people of Ukraine are embolden and
NATO has never been stronger
as President Biden and secretary Austin
repeatedly said the United States
remains committed as long as it takes
thank you and I look forward to your
questions
first question go to Richmond Cohen
defense news
hi thanks for doing this I have one
question for each of you Mr chairman we
know from the recent leagues that the
Pentagon was bullish on Ukraine's
Champion now or what has changed and are
you concerned that spring conditions on
the ground will slow things down and
then for secretary Austin looking at the
current crisis in Sudan what Lessons
Learned From the Afghanistan evacuation
are shaping your efforts to prepare to
get U.S embassy staff out of Sudan and
has the state department ask you to
begin that process
well let me uh let me start by saying
that I'm already comment on future
operations specifically uh or any of the
substances any of these leaks that are
out there but I will say that our tasks
and our commitment to Ukraine was to
provide the training and the equipment
for up to nine brigades armored brigades
armored Mech brigades to conduct either
offensive or defensive operations those
brigades are trained they're manned and
their equipment and they are prepared
for combat operation so whenever and
wherever Ukraine chooses to use them we
will continue that support and I am very
confident in those units ability to
succeed
regarding Sudan the department through
our headquarters in Africa and continues
to monitor very closely the situation on
the ground
and we continue to coordinate with uh
with the state department to make sure
we have a common vision
of what the situation is
um
we always want to make sure that we're
doing food and planning which is what
we're doing we've
uh
we deployed some forces to into
theater to ensure that we
provide as many options as possible if
we are called Barn to do something and
we haven't been called
on anything yet another season on
anything has been made
and for operation security purposes and
you would guess I I won't specify you
know
I've moved to and but our focus is to
make sure that we continue to do a crude
planning
and that we create and maintain as many
options for our
thank you our next question will go to
English
now my question is going to be to both
according fighter jets Ukraine said that
they need more fighter jets Poland has
just delivered links
did you talk about fighter jets and how
helpful could they be for Ukraine
right now what uh what we all believe is
what Ukraine needs most urgently he is
ground-based air defense capability
that is what has enabled them to prevent
the Russian Air Forces from having a
meaning meaningful impact in this
and so you've heard us say that uh for
the last several months we will continue
to say that because that is what is is
is most important in the current and the
future uh fight at the immediate future
we have to make sure that the ukrainians
have the ability to protect their
infrastructure protect their citizens
but also protect troops if the troops
are renewing so we we continue to engage
our partners and
and allies and emphasize that we need to
do everything we can to ensure that
Ukraine has adequate air defense
ground-based air defense capability and
I have to applaud the work that our
partners are doing
where possible they're stepping up to
the plate I believe that that we can
still do more and I'm asking them to do
more and believe that they will
want our next question we'll go to a
little Dunlop agency
thank you secretary Austin our contact
group members working to speed up
deliveries of military supplies
especially key items such as artillery
rounds ahead of you grants
counter-offensive and does Ukraine have
the items it needs for that offensive
and chairman Billy um do you think the
Abrams Tanks will have a significant
impact once they arrive on the
battlefield in Ukraine the US is
previously expressed concerns about
logistics and sustainment for the tanks
have those concerns have been
sufficiently addressed I
and so several months ago as we we set
out to plan as our people set out to
plan with the Ukrainian partners
uh we outline the parameters for you
know you know potential operations and
we designed uh the support that would be
required to to support those operations
uh and we laid that out in detail and we
that that set us on a path to generate
combat power combat capability uh you've
heard us talk about the the combat
platforms the tanks the Bradleys uh the
striker the strikers Martyrs CB 90s and
all of the sustainment that goes along
with that in all of the Munitions
required to uh to be successful
as you just heard uh both what the
chairman and I said uh this was uh this
was uh really difficult work but we have
met our initial goals to provide what's
required to uh to get started and and we
will and we know that combat is dynamic
complex and so we understand that we're
going to have to continue to sustain
Ukraine's efforts uh going forward uh
when the fight starts and long after the
Fight Continues
it's on the M1 tank you know unbiased
but I think the M1 Tank's the best tank
in the world there are other tanks that
are quite good the leopards for example
being provided as well but I do think
the M1 tank when it is uh delivered will
make a difference now let me distinguish
between uh in a couple weeks you're
going to get training tanks those aren't
quite combat capable and they'll be used
to train the crews on how to shoot
maneuver and maintain these tanks and
that is part of the sustainment package
to get them trained up as the other
tanks are being refurbished in order for
to accelerate their delivery but when
they do get here and those crews are
trained and they're used in a combined
ornament over uh
tactic in combination with Mech infantry
the Bradley's they'll be very effective
but I would also caution there's no
silver bulletin boards it's a Wars the
outcomes of battles and Wars are the
function of many many variables and in
this case you would have to make sure
that your tanks are used in Combined
arms with mechanized infantry artillery
all of that is synchronized with
dismounted forces
Etc so there is no Silver Bullet in this
case but I do think the M1 tank when
it's delivered and reaches its
operational capability that it'll be
very effective on the battlefield
thank you and our last question will go
to Claire accommier tf1
thank you one question for separately do
you really believe in a successful
country because here today we mainly uh
hear about sustainability and the
long-term ad and if this Conservancy it
doesn't lead to a Ukrainian Victory
quickly do you think that Biden
Administration we still have the support
of the American people to continue to
help Ukraine and if at the time one
quick question to General Miley you have
been asked about deaths but if there are
any chance that the United States
changed the mind about the delivery of
F-16
thank you so clear your question is
whether or not we can expect to continue
to have support for Ukraine
well we we've enjoyed uh strong support
from the American people throughout for
for this uh this effort this campaign
and that support has enabled the
ukrainians to be
as successful as they have been on the
battlefield I have to credit the
ukrainians for their will to fight for
the Ingenuity for their professionalism
for their leadership but uh even when
you have all of that you can't get it
done unless you have the right gear and
and
and you were able to sustain your
efforts and so we've worked together to
help create the Dynamics that we've seen
thus far we're going to continue to work
so we've enjoyed uh
apart from the American people
throughout
I am I'm very hopeful that we'll
continue to see that same level of
support uh and uh and again
this is not just important to the
Ukrainian people
it's important to the world
this is about the rules-based
international order this is about uh you
know a a bully not having the the
ability to travel his uh his smaller
neighbor at will
this is about protecting or providing
the opportunity for a country to protect
its Sovereign ranks
so on the uh
F-16 or any other fourth generation
aircraft from any other country you know
first of all those are policy questions
will be made by political leaders but
from a military
perspective the task
is to control the airspace
how you control that airspace can be
done in many many different ways the
most cost effective efficient and way to
do that right now for Ukraine uh and the
fastest way to do that for Ukraine is to
rear defense they've been doing it for
over a year now they've been denying the
airspace to effective Russian use the
Russians have been flying some sorties
into Ukraine but limited amounts of
sorties over Russian occupied Ukraine
they have Russians have not done
Battlefield they are in addiction deep
into Ukraine territory except through
missiles and Rockets that have been
fired from over Russian territory why is
that done by the Russians because of the
Ukraine and the shooting Russian
aircraft down so the Russians are
cautious to come into Ukraine because of
the effective use of the Ukrainian air
defense system that is the most critical
thing right now is that air defense
system to make sure that it is robust
it's rigorous it's deep and it's layered
from high altitude to mid-altitude to
low altitude and from short range
mid-range to long range and the front
line forces the Ukrainian Frontline
forces need to be protected that's the
most important critical military task
right now that was the theme of this
entire day was air defense air defense
air defense to make sure that Ukraine
can defend its airspace in terms of the
aircraft themselves there's a long lead
time for uh
the training of Pilots Etc and the
Russians have a significant amount of
their power and to take the Ukrainian
Air Force from where it is today and to
build it up and match the Russian Air
Force that's a significant level of
effort by lots of countries and those
policy choices may or may not be made
down the road and we'll see where that
goes but right now the immediate need is
their defense
secretary Austin General Lee thank you
very much gentlemen ladies and gentlemen
this concludes our press briefing thank
you very much for joining us today
thank you